et jérémy stop ce bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france on
lisait la france a finalement suspendu
jusqu'à jeudi les sanctions concernant
les navires britanniques des sanctions
qui devait entrer en vigueur aujourd'hui
quelle est la réaction du côté du
royaume uni après cette annonce du
président français
on dirait que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle parce qu'il s'agit évidemment
d'apaiser les tensions et tension étant
considérable alors ce délai et est un
très bon signe parce que
monsieur macro et monsieur johnson
semble être dans un bras de fer est
derrière tout ça il n'y pas que la
question de la pêche bien sûr donc qu'il
faut il faut qu'il y a une occasion pour
que les deux leaders puisse en quelque
sorte
rétropédaler un peu pour pouvoir en fait
trouver un compromis cela est toujours
possible donc c'est une bonne nouvelle
alors vous l'avez bien s'il n'y a pas
que la pêche au chalut il ya eu les
vaccins il ya eu l'histoire des sous
marins vendus à l'australie paris veut
montrer les muscles avons là la prise en
fonction de la présidence de l'union
européenne y penser
oui ça doit rentrer dans l'équation à
mon avis
[Musique]
les relations entre le royaume uni et la
france ont commencé à se détériorer il y
a quand même un certain temps c'est
l'histoire de toutes les négociations
pour le break site parce que il y a eu
trois séries de négociations d'abord
l'accord de retrait ensuite l'accord
commercial et ensuite l'application sur
le protocole de l'irlande du nord et
nous sommes toujours au milieu de ces
dernières négociations
je pense que vu de londres le
gouvernement français est perçu comme
l'état membre le plus intransigeant le
plus difficile des vingt sept est donc
exactement à l'époque de mad men
le vice président de la commission
européenne maros sefcovic édite plus en
plus inquiets que le gouvernement
britannique s'engage sur la voie de la
confrontation est ce que c'est l'état de
l'esprit de londres aujourd'hui
je pense que
ce qu'on voit et dans une certaine
mesure c'était prévisible étant donné
les difficultés
d'arriver à un modus vivendi
entre
l'union européenne et un ex-membre le
premier ex membres et
comme comme tout le monde le sait il
n'ya pas que la question de la pêche il
y aussi la question de léo land du nord
il ya aussi la question
des alliances dans l'inde au pacifique
il ya beaucoup de sujets de tension à la
fois donc qu'il est toujours inévitable
qu'il y ait ces difficultés maintenant
l'important c'est de les surmonter et il
s'est toujours possible on n'est pas en
train de rentrer en guerre les propos
sur l'irlande du nord de la france
d'ailleurs avait choqué les autorités
britanniques un disons que c'était
différent finalement dû du royaume uni
est ce que le montrer que le breakbeat
finalement est un échec ce n'est pas là
finalement la grille de lecture
oui nous avons vu par exemple cette
lettre de la part de monsieur castex à
la présidente de la commission qui
disait qu'il fallait montrer qu' il ya
plus de dommages
le niveau pn que à rester dedans donc il
ya sans doute une volonté de montrer que
le break c'était une mauvaise idée et on
peut douter
ce que les
les hauts fonctionnaires français est
vraiment compris le break site
l'ancienne ambassadrice londres a publié
un livre qui est une dénonciation à la
fois du président et de boris johnson
c'est une curieuse manière de pratiquer
la diplomatie finalement sur ce conflit
sur la pêche qu'il a raison qui a tort
sans vous
je pense que c'est sûrement un peu des
deux côtés
mais
je crois que quand on voit la pêche dans
le contexte le plus large on peut
distribuer sans doute un peu les torts
des deux côtés l'important maintenant
c'est de d'apaiser les tensions ce qui
semble être le cas pour le moment donc
nous avons jusqu'à jeudi pour voir si
les choses s'améliorent ça va
s'améliorer
ce serait très intelligent
que ça se passe comme ça parce qu'il y à
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
en jeu en ce moment et nous savons que
dans le contexte actuel
sur le plan par exemple militaires et
stratégiques
droit et miner la france en un très
grand intérêt à coopérer et ce serait
vraiment
contre-productif de
gâcher tout ce que nous avons tout ce
que nous possédons commun puisque
finalement cette relation d'amour haine
est quand même assez ancienne entre la
france et la grande bretagne
oui bien sûr bien sûr vous savez que le
royaume uni et la france
à part quelques incidents sont alliés
depuis
le soir de la bataille de mortal ou donc
il y a quand même une longue histoire de
coopération et aujourd'hui cette
coopération comme je le disais tout alla
est absolument nécessaire nous sans nous
engager
à
autour de la planète ensemble dans sur
différents théâtres donc
il est nécessaire de rétablir cette
apparence de coopération parce que il y
à une véritable coopération comme c'est
souvent le cas
quand les leaders ne s'entendent pas
très bien d'autres personnes d'autres
acteurs plus bas dans la hiérarchie en
quelque sorte continuent à coopérer
c'est le cas aujourd'hui les militaires
les marins britanniques et français qu
aux prêts au jour le jour donc il est
important que le désaccord ne ne descend
pas sur toute la pyramide des opérations
il faut que les leaders se mettent
d'accord quand même assez rapidement
merci beaucoup jérémy stock d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes président de
l'association des conservateurs
britanniques de paris